[Music]
hey everybody i don't know if that's
good
hey everybody it's chong's eye ethan
exotic
and uh they didn't think it was possible
but they brought us together it's carol
masking
hey all you cool cats and kittens it's
trisha baskins here
tricia baskin i have a confession to
make
to trisha baskins i don't know why but i
have the inexplicable urge to want to
murder you you should say unalive if you
don't want to get censored that's what
they say i'm alive
they say on a live on tick tock when you
talk about i'm gonna unalive you so hard
that's the censored version thank you um
how do you feel as carol do you feel
like you've
embodying a sense of i love her i think
i i just started watching tiger king
like a year
late to the trend like i'm so late to it
but i love it we watch it at night
and i just feel like i'm like her in so
many ways and i just love her and i
think she's a queen
and what way are you liking her um she
killed her husband
and she did but we haven't gotten to
that part yet i don't think she
well i well joe exotic made a whole song
about how she did
and i believe him joe exotic is so
iconic like
i think originally eli came up with the
idea we're like oh it's kind of outdated
whatever but then i watched it and i was
like no this is iconic we got to do
these we're
here late but it's playing well yeah the
hair i'm glad that i get to use my
natural hair
you look like him like you did come on
bring that sweet ass over here let me
take a lick
he was gay i didn't you know that but
yeah he had two husbands yeah that guy
liked to [ __ ]
come on boy i like the whole gay redneck
thing it's just
it's just like an interesting character
so why didn't they get a reality show
it's so interesting it's like why didn't
you have fun
he wouldn't ever have to kill carol
baskin he could have been just well hold
on they had made a reality show about
him but then he [ __ ] burned down the
whole farm to
to erase the footage that's crazy
because there was all this incriminating
footage of him mistreating his animals
or some [ __ ] like that
right and then he burned i didn't get
that part too he went down i'm so
confused with the whole story
yeah allegedly he's so good though he
was doing music videos and podcasts like
he's so entertaining like
it's scary that people that would like
me like unaliving somebody one day or
like you know what i mean like if you're
so like unexpected you can say kill on
youtube
kenya i'm so used to tick-tock like on
alive
online i know i feel like on youtube all
of a sudden because
we're always on like eggshells on
youtube
but tick-tock is way worse for example i
made
what i think is the most slam-dunk
tick-tock on james charles
it was going mega viral it had 2.5
million views in like 12 hours
i was feeling like a million bucks and
here comes tick tock they erased it for
harassment and bullying which is just
i'm sorry here's the tick tock i have it
here i haven't yeah i saw it
you guys tell me do you think this is
harassment in bowling i don't
congratulations james charles on your
kids choice award
it's perfect because i know that kids
have always been your choice so
oh that works out perfectly ops
nickelodeon
keep an eye on him during the after
party
how is that harassment um that's
definitely not
like he's a public figure literally a
predator and i'm caught and i'm bringing
that's like someone saying like oh r
kelly enjoy your sex
dungeons and they're like sorry leave
for arc ellie alone
and no but for years people did they're
like like people defended our cali like
for
literally it's totally the same thing
and it's crazy
nothing's changed that's true or the
lopez brothers are back doing trends
like we're not going anywhere
the lopez brothers are out there [ __ ]
like oh tap dancing on the haters
he's confessing that he had a
relationship with a 14 year old girl
on the mother literally recorded herself
and this guy's like [ __ ] the haters
i don't get this world i don't either i
think it's a cra i guess if you people
just don't press charges and nothing
happens i guess
it's just kids i don't know but like
james charles like he's like
out there with the kardashians he's out
there winning kids choice awards
the dude i was like oh this is too
perfect you know his choice is
kids i mean how ironic that he's getting
a kid's
i did choice really clever because it's
true you know i mean it wrote itself i
was like oh
kids choice award no but there sounds it
sounds like
it sounds like his preference you know
it sounds like they're calling him a
pedal right up like a kid's choice award
but the fact that tick-tock is like
letting him like they're defending him
they're like hiding in protecting him
yeah that's like even weirder
i made another tick talk about him and
it got removed for bowling and
harassment
if you even mention james charles it
gets taken down for that i i've
i sit and only james charles videos are
getting removed for harassment
yeah the same that was mine too that's
why i thought i stopped i'm like if you
want to hear my
opinions on james i go to my youtube
channel because like i could not put on
tick tock like
it's crazy it's crazy that they should
be platform him but now there's someone
there protecting him
yeah i guess i don't know same thing
with the local brothers
the lopez brothers they should be in
jail they should be out there tap
dancing in prison
there's no [ __ ] place in society for
these people but they're allowed to have
those accounts still like that's real
because t
is really strict they banned press
hilton but not them like it's so weird
it's like okay
like they're actually sexting people off
here it's so sad
right they're committing the crimes on
that platform
that's the crazy part is that they're
they're messaging people they're using
their platform
to connect with a young audience i saw a
tic tac i don't know the girl's name who
made it but it had like
millions of views by the time i saw it
i'll just repeat what she said she said
something like you know r kelly would
like
you know go to like mcdonald's in the
mall
i got to show you this because this is a
different platform you guys go ahead
and and like basically like you know
because he knows he's famous and so the
young fans are going to come to him
that's the same thing james charles did
he saw him on the explore page like this
kid didn't even message him first
he messaged him went on the snapchat
like snapchat is only used for one thing
so to say
his intentions were bad i'm like go off
you like
what like it's so crazy so it'll be a
james charles situation for sure
i think even like david dobrik will be a
harvey weinstein in the future because
harvey weinstein got away with it for so
long
no because i got more stories i don't
want to say anything but there's more
stories that have come out like
to me but to other people too that have
come out and i was like wow this is like
crazy that there's like
repeated things of like girls being
drugged girls being drunk like all the
stuff of them like david
and for his vlogs of him instructing
other people to get it i won't say like
allegedly whatever but like
i already heard oh we can't say that i
just wanted to talk about have you said
too much
no i don't think so so okay this is
james charles on tick tock the modern
day version now this is one of my
favorite videos
on the internet maybe this this is this
to me is
treasure okay this is r kelly in
ethiopia
literally grooming people on stage
during a song he has a grooming song
he has a grooming song called do you
have your passports do you have your
shots
watch this this is literally james
charles on tick tock modern day
i've been swearing you have your
passports
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come
back with rob to america
yeah yeah america
yeah this is what r kelly's doing in
ethiopia did you
you should cover
do you think there's any possibility
he's just trying to help unfortunate
children poverty
[Music]
now knowing what we know about him he's
saying girl do you have your passports
do you have your shots what do you think
he's doing with kids from ethiopia you
think he's going to
get him back and put him in school
michael jackson no he put him in his
[ __ ] rape dungeon
he had a rape dungeon did you see
surviving arkell i did not know
dude he had like a [ __ ] like there
was a room in his house where the girls
would walk through and they'd be like
i can't even talk about what happened in
here horrible horror really
yeah what happened is he in prison now
yes he is he is
he's in [ __ ] prison hope for james
charles to get his justice served one
day
well you could start by not doing
chipotle collabs you know what i mean
why is chipotle sponsored do you know if
he was sponsored for sure or maybe he
was just doing it on his own
oh he's it's he says in partnership with
chipotle here let me pull that up
so the day after i heard chipotle is
like the pizza thing remember pizza
oh by the way i didn't even say it but
um we're doing the cook-off today
shouldn't we say that oh yeah yeah cause
i was wanting to eat
well you you've been stepping to me hold
that thought i'm curious what you were
gonna say
there's a video not right in the game
again people have been
sh trish has been stepping to me why am
i floof look at my floof
no it's not first of all it's not a
floof it's good it's all tangled no it's
fine
a joke's hog would never step outside
looking like this all mangled up
um trisha been stepping to me with her
all her bottled noodles [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] the butternoodle queen bibby
with babish and all this [ __ ]
i love babish don't oh my god don't come
for babbage i just said
okay i'll never come for babies i'll
never bid with i'll never bid that
babbish i was supposed to bring my own
pot and butter and we forgot it because
it was hectic this morning at my house
so we totally got it
but i feel like it's not like mine my
butter is something well you [ __ ] up
you already you already put yourself at
a disadvantage
i'm still gonna win so on the menu we're
cooking we picked
four diverse dishes mashed potatoes four
i thought we had three
mashed potatoes eggs steak and pasta's
not part of it
don't make me go back in the chat yeah
don't use there go back in the chat it
was not part of it
steak was not because i never cooked
steak in my life you said you were going
to practice this week oh yeah i forgot i
had like six kids at my house under the
age of six so i was a lot of
i don't admit that but i'll try i watch
tiger king and they fed steaks to the
tigers
i'm ready yeah if you have access to the
frenemies chat somebody's got a bat
moses come on you know i'm right we
brought it up
yes thank you say no more say no more
okay fine you know what i actually love
steak i can't wait did you do what kind
did you get fillet
fillet okay i can cook a flavor thank
you actually i don't know i've never
cooked one in my life but i will try
um so we have four we have four
categories and then because
last time we did the cake and by the way
when we did the cake you read the
comments i trust and everybody said i
won wait what is that
oh no it's poor shredder puked is he
okay
yeah he pukes a lot i'm sorry shreddy
you okay
is it like is it because he's sick or
eating related
no he he has this condition where he
gets too much acid in his stomach
and then in the morning usually because
he hasn't eaten yet he
kicks out pugs and poor shredder like he
doesn't
he doesn't eat he's like a he's not good
he's like an eating disorder
any legend yeah he is he has to choose
trigger warning before he it's a dog
but i i try everything to feed this
[ __ ] dog like i cook him steak i cook
a chicken you know what i mean like i do
ever i bend backwards for this dog to
try to feed him it's like a huge
stress point in my life is trying to get
treated to eat really
have you ever heard of a dog like that
yeah no my dog loves everything food i
just uh
well anyway anyway we have four diverse
categories
okay well the cake thing i obviously won
but everyone was afraid to vote against
you
do you admit that now definitely not
everybody in the comments is saying i
won
that's so not sure oh the comments are
your people still bruh
very few people are okay well regardless
everybody knows that i won the cake off
but
the [ __ ] judging was just so rigged
so what i've done here today
i brought elis coming in but that's a
ring
no she's gonna be impartial elise
doesn't care to dunk on me
but like these guys are scared you can't
ask someone like a.b to
davey's scared of you he's literally
terrified of you
moses is terrified of you too he's not
going to vote against you that is not
true
okay well anyway for the record yeah i
didn't vote for trisha because i was
scared of her
thank you i voted for her because i felt
bad because i knew she was gonna get
blown out
okay see this and what happened oh my
god
and then a b is the one who [ __ ] it
all up by simping for you
what so why did you why would did you
vote out of feeling better
because you were afraid of how you would
react no well if more
it was more sympathy than fear it was
sympathy not fear okay
okay whatever regardless we're trying
i'm trying to keep a fair panel so we
have
ela moses and a third celebrity
oh is it babish it's not fabish it's mac
demarco
friend of the show he's a friend of the
show well he's not actually a friend
he's a friend of mine but he's a fan of
the show
really uh famous musician one of my
favorites matt demarco ladies and
gentlemen we'll be here
as our celebrity impartial judge can we
get him on the show
um well let's ask him have you hear this
happen
yeah he's on the show oh he's going to
film with us yes he's going to be our
judge
where's he going well we're all going to
go upstairs when we start cooking
oh we really need a guest spot for when
we have guests
we need if we have a guest it needs to
be something really incredible
i think max miller marco is right you
don't even know who he is i love him i
did look him up i love him i love him
oh my god you do you love names i just
don't know names but i do love him and i
love that he loves us
i don't know any songs i love him i do
love him for real like i looked him up i
was like oh my god this guy likes us
like
it's very cool he's a big deal he's just
no i know he's a superstar
anyway i think he's gonna ghost you like
post malone
maybe if he gets too famous he's like
bye i don't want him getting too famous
maybe we shouldn't because then i'll
lose another friend
i don't feel bad if i ghost you when i
become super famous because i'll be like
oh posted it i know how it is
do you think i'll ghost you
when you become more famous and then
your path to fame as we
just to recap is this show yeah so i'm
still confused on where
on that path of you becoming so famous
you need to ghost me but can i say but
i'm okay with that i don't think carol
basket would be as famous as she didn't
kill her husband
or on alive or whatever we saved him
yeah so she did a good business decision
killing him
she got to be on dancing with the stars
that would never happen if he was alive
carol baskin wachter
i want to do that on my tech talk i want
to do it on my channel okay all right
calm down
so anyway what was i talking about i
feel crazy i was around six kids this
weekend and i like never
have children i feel nuts oh you're all
crazy i'm out i'm out okay
okay it was a lot there's just so much
screaming on cocoa melon
oh cocoa melon oh good i love cocoa
melon
i can't if you're happy and you know
babies
that's kind of a slot it's not theodore
loves it and then he goes
mommy shark a daddy shark i can't
i like you should have one you should
just stick with one because once you
start having more they start yelling
screaming at each other and start riling
each other up it's gonna be a lot
no we want more than one we love
theodore we want more babies
perfect we want more babies we're having
more babies
you are we're trying very hard i think
i'm done
we're trying so hard we're doing all
this crazy fertility stuff this month
yeah and i'm injecting
oh [ __ ] like um hormones into her
stomach every day
oh into her it's not yours not into mine
yeah
it's to make her like [ __ ] more fertile
it's crazy that's hard
and it's like super painful the doctor
goes to eli he goes
this is how you know it's [ __ ] up she
goes okay so
this is gonna sting a lot she showed us
how to do it the first time
and you know you're in for a world of
pain when the doctor goes this is going
to hurt a lot
really it doesn't hurt yeah it burns i
feel like you look so tough though i
feel like you
don't care she's like she almost passed
out the first time the doctor did it
but actually it's gotten a lot better
it's a it's a baby needle so it's about
that long
oh my god so i grab her her stomach and
like bunch the skin
and then oh slam as hard as i can no i
don't it goes
you know keto is bad for fertility like
it especially guys on keto like it like
triples my balls i think it's just like
lower testosterone like lower um
sperm count yeah i'm not doing it
anymore well you did it and maybe it
[ __ ] you up
well i've been off for i've been off
keto and for now for a long time
like a week it feels like i haven't seen
you a long time
i get so sad when i watch the h3 that
you're by yourself now when you listen
i'm like awesome everyone's sad it's fun
though it's fun we're figuring out we
have to figure out a way to make it fun
maybe get another co-host no
i don't i don't i can't have that many
people but i think you vibe really well
with a female so fine
like you need to find like a um why i
have i have ela and i have you you i
don't need any more [ __ ] co-hosts in
my life
um carol baska maybe carol baskin would
you do a podcast with her
what will we talk about just like every
week you just do a little check-in
hey so how did any news on your lost
husband no
okay you don't know what she's talking
anyways this is such old news i'm so
into it now so i'm always like having
all your questions
but anyways we're gonna talk about james
james charles i'm i'm just so sad when
there's no drama like i wasn't that
excited there's drama i have [ __ ] there
is wrong yeah there's there's
i like when there's like stuff happening
so james charles is a predator
um there's a lot on that james the james
charles issue is way to me worse than
david doberg in my opinion like david
dobrik needs to answer
for what he's done to seth and the way
that they're like
attacking seth and all that is messed up
but james charles
is out there looking for people that
have had their shots and passports
looking to go back to america
can i say what was said to me about
david everett or no about the lawyer
thing or no
you don't think it should i wish dude
i'm almost just gonna say [ __ ] it
can i just say that i heard from david's
lawyer but not directly i heard it
indirectly
go ahead say it for the record if
someone says something to me they're
like
off the record don't repeat this like
don't tell me like don't leave it's her
fault
she shouldn't have told you a damn thing
such a it's such a what is the word i
want to say the word trigger but i get
so
triggered like i was pissed like i
called you right away i like listen to
the group chat
something i learned very early about
being friends with you is never confide
anything in you
and i mean and i say that with peace and
love he's in love i say that with all
the peace and love in the room i i tell
people this once i say that to me i'm
like just for the record i can't be off
the record like i just
i can't but um yeah so anyways this was
a very
it was a very exciting development in my
opinion because i had never heard from
david or jason ever
ever not even you know csun decision
those are like whatever throwing
statement just says someone they
literally don't give a [ __ ] but i
haven't even gotten that so i was like
okay
which by the way everything i say is
true like whatever blah blah blah but i
heard
indirectly from david's lawyer so david
zorro sent a letter to somebody else
about me and that said that i and they
try to imply that i was
defaming them or defamatory although i
haven't heard anything about it
um whatever i don't can't should we say
it or should just like leave no no keep
going
okay i'm just gonna say what let's what
so insiders doing this article about
david dobrik in the vlog squad it's not
a secret everybody knows they're working
on it like involved because they've
reached everything
and so they've obviously talked to you
and so what happened was they
the lawyers sent this letter to them
about
trisha i think they're publishing part
of it they said they had to publish part
of the letter
so anyway they sent the letter i'm just
trying to make sure everyone understands
we're not doing anything wrong here
you not doing anything hey i'm washing
my hands nothing wrong though
not me peace and love we're
foreshadowing our future with joe exotic
and carol baskin right here okay
um okay so here's what happened is that
david's lawyer
sent a letter to insider about you
about me and then insider sent it to you
for comment yeah cause it's pretty
lengthy because it
the article itself isn't about me and
like before the record too like before
the record off the record whatever i
don't know what this means i just love
to say foreign on the record
we are on the record right now on the
record on the record
for the record um like i actually only
talked to business insider literally
once and i've always like ignored their
emails because like
it's just like a lot and to me i always
like i i don't know i don't really keep
up with business so i just never really
commented
um this one i actually had like some
insight on because it's an incident i've
talked about even before this like art
this article came out but
um girls have come forward with this
incident i talked about it whatever and
so they did a whole piece
these girls have reached out or spoke to
them and so i gave my comment well then
the lawyers commented on my comments
what is the incident
um so it was basically a night that i
was there at the apartment and i'm the
only girl on the vlog besides these
girls it's underage girls some of them
underage some of them under drinking age
so there's like so basically dom said
all five girls want to have sex with
them they got there they didn't want to
have sex with them they're like we just
want to meet david uh whatever you know
what i mean and that's
totally fine but basically they didn't
want to do it they just wanted to meet
david so when he's like come on do it
they're like no
and so that's when david allegedly here
we go whatever
but i was there so it was allegedly if i
was there because he did he just said
he told jason go get them alcohol to
like loosen them up
he said that yeah oh and jason did it
can i say this i don't know if i should
the lawyer's response and the response
was like david would never do that
well that's not illegal that's not a
legal defense that's basically what
dom's
are that's what the scotty's defense of
david was too the he would never do they
doesn't mean boating in his body
oh my god so he has jason and i was
there and i'm gonna say like fortunately
i was there because i told jason i'm
like these girls we don't know how old
they are like they look so young to me
and i was like and i knew they were
definitely under a drinking age because
they couldn't go buy the alcohol like we
can't buy the alcohol like we're not old
enough
so jason was gonna go and i was like
don't do that like you're literally
gonna buy underage girls like alcohol so
jason didn't
and then jeff jeff went and i believe
like todd i think too and they went and
got
um alcohol and jeff talked about it on a
barbershop how uncomfortable he was so
he had todd like buy it on his credit
card like something crazy
they didn't say the direct incident but
it was obviously the same thing so
business insider has this article out
about it whatever
and i was like i'm gonna give comments
not out yeah it's coming out this week
or something
yeah it's not yet but i was like i can
give comment to this because i've talked
about it before and like i was never my
story to share really about these girls
but these i guess two girls came forward
one who was like black
and one who was sober who did the
driving whoa so
um that is so shady well what's so crazy
is the spin they did on it so then the
lawyers instead of
that's so slimy hold on i have to take a
minute
so david just simply because he wanted
to make a good content
got went and got underage girls alcohol
to loosen them up
yeah did they end up sleeping with dawn
so in the vlog it does
in the vlog he says they're not having
it they weren't feeling it then it cuts
and he's like
with a little bit of like coursing they
were able to get three three of the
girls night
no it's i have the deleted one yeah i
they
i have the i have we course three girls
just sleeping with them
that's like what the [ __ ] do you want to
watch to get the exact quote but like
that was so anyways and then but then
this so they go in to have sex
so then you see like todd jeff and jonah
like listening at this point me and
jason are gone because like
right away i was like this is a bad
situation and i felt for the girls like
they definitely were like
so uncomfortable with everything and so
i was like we have to go so we left but
it cuts to the vlog where they're having
sex with dom and like everyone's like
listening in and like looking in on them
and stuff like that and so
the one girl said she was completely
blacked out one girl was sober because
she drove and remembered and like i said
i wasn't there for the whole thing i was
just there for the alcohol part and i
like just remembered that so vividly
and i got a couple of the girls have
like quotes from jason that he said like
creepy stuff to them
and stuff whatever and my the reason i
commented on it was because
i could like i could finally back up
this girl's story because i was there
like a lot of these stories i can't back
up because i wasn't there but that one i
was like okay i can back up that they
did not want to do it they didn't they
said they were underage
that they couldn't buy alcohol that's
what i'm saying underage did that and
he wanted jason to originally do it and
then he got jeff to go do it
but what's the craziest thing and i just
this is what i'm saying don't tell me
this stuff because i will get triggered
and i know everyone knows this by the
way because people will love to trigger
me about moses or whatever they try and
make up [ __ ] because they want to
trigger me
or even stuff from the past whatever
because i do get triggered as [ __ ] but
david's lawyer's defense was an attack
on me
so trying to like this situation had
nothing to do with me
except trying to discredit me in their
in their thing basically discrediting
saying that i've been bullying and
harassing jason and david
that i've been stalking them and and
that that
i'm not a credible source because i am a
violent i have history of mental illness
and that's why
jason broke up with me which the lawyers
got it wrong anyways because i did the
video before he even broke up with me so
i was just like
it's so frustrating that these lawyers
and they try to like insinuate that they
had a case against me that i was
defaming them in some way i've never
heard from their lawyers like
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] like basically
saying don't run this article blah blah
blah so i don't know maybe the article
won't run i have no idea what's
happening but they sent a super
well i trisha told me about i haven't
seen the letter but
they sent a super threatening letter to
insider saying that you cannot use
trisha as a source because she is
like mentally unstable yeah can you
believe the the balls on these [ __ ]
guys
it's crazy it's so crazy to me because
now we know from scott we know from all
these people that like
not only are they not sorry they're like
doubling down saying like they're
totally in the right they were never in
the wrong in any situation
like first of all if they're gonna
accuse you of harassing and stalking
them
there's literally no people show that
there's no restraining order right
because i listen to their podcast
yeah that's stalking i mean that's like
what people keep saying i literally
they try to say that i was like her i
was violent towards david i'm like all
this crazy stuff that i showed up to his
house i've never done that i was like
there would be camera footage the only
thing i admit to is may 8th
2019 when i went to jason's house that's
like the only thing
you did drive your car through jason's
house with like the brick through the
whipping i admit to that that part i
admit but
to say that i was violent towards david
or anything like that like and i admit
to it like
you drove your car through jason's house
not like through it but i was definitely
like i
honestly was so high i literally don't
remember like i just remember i guess
apparently i threw a brick through it
which is totally i totally believe
i don't you drove your car i believe you
threw a brick through the window i was
just like so [ __ ] up i was so [ __ ]
up it was so embarrassing
and i admit if jason wants to do me for
that like you knew me for that okay that
i admit i wouldn't you see
bombs you're literally the guy at the
royal tenenbaums who drove his car into
the funeral you remember that dan
that's you thank you that's that's is
that owen wilson who is yeah i love
wilson i relate i guess
like no honestly oh they've been saying
i've been trying to defame that i mean
to be fair that is pretty good
that is a pretty strong mark against you
of course but keep in mind this is all
after this and this is months later that
was me
but also you're not the they made it
sound like you're the only sole account
of this story you're just corroborating
these girls
well she says i've been attacking and
trying to defame them it's like no i've
been sharing my story the same story
over and over
can i can i remind everybody i share the
same thing it's not like i'm like oh
this thing this thing i can share my
truth and i can speak out about it and
if other people are coming forward
and you're sharing your opinion you're
not like david did this thing that never
happened like we're just if you got a
problem david just [ __ ] sue
sue no but also like i think i prefer if
you don't too but i'm up game for it
well he's like
can't he can't like he's admitted on the
podcast too that like he's had jason
like
take the wrath for his speeding tickets
because if he gets like arrested that
is a big crime it affects his
immigration daddy that's the thing
because he's docker right he's daca so
if he gets arrested it could affect his
immigration status so he said like
he talked he admitted a couple times he
talked to a police officer out of giving
him a ticket
because for speeding in his ferrari and
i think another time
i might be wrong on this one but like he
did he did shift the blame to someone
else
you could get a speeding ticket i don't
think you can commit like a felon no i
think
i swear he said he's like because he's
always like a celebrity so he gets like
he could get a different kind of brain
and all this stuff like that you can get
like a celebrity bottom line though you
can't you can discredit me all you want
but it's like also all these people
coming forward with their stories like
have nothing to do with me like seth had
nothing to do with me big kind of thing
yeah this girl has nothing to do with me
really other than i was there they asked
me for comment
i was there i was a sound mind like i
can tell you when i'm not in a sound
mind that's
that's crazy that david gave alcohol to
underage girls to juice
up his vlog like dude these how could
you care that much about your vlog
that's like
that's some real psycho thing oh you
can't blame david it's like he's
literally the one that was like
encouraging this for his vlog like it's
so disgusting it was so gross i mean you
can because and he like documented that
and all this crazy [ __ ] do any of the
girls who slept with him feel like they
were like
violated is that the scoop or i actually
don't know what the girl said i actually
haven't talked to the
girl they had i think one of them very
happy a while ago
you don't know i don't think how do they
find anybody i feel like business
insiders and
super sleuth so um anyways i was i was
relieved
i just feel like uh as being like in
that position it just feels good to like
at least share your story and like get
it out there because like it sucks it
sucks that people get away with stuff
and you have to like watch people get
away with stuff and like
i'm profiting off of it like profiting
and being embarrassed and humiliated and
all this [ __ ] it's like it's not
that's way worse than anything i've
heard well the set thing is bad but
that's like a whole nother level
yeah no that one was really bad so that
article is coming out sometime i don't
know when but i can't wait to read it
yeah i mean i really don't like to be
the like the person because like when i
heard that letter from the lawyers like
it did make me feel some type of way
that people
like how everyone else sees me like
trish is crazy just this whatever but
i don't know i'll keep talking about it
because as oprah says i
will not be silenced unless i am
silenced
right silent i will not be silenced
unless no i'm not going to be silent
unless i'm silenced didn't you see the
interview oh with meghan markle she goes
were you silent or were you silenced
i'm right did you see it i saw bits of
it you're not a mega miracle fan
i'm not i just the whole royal thing is
just so stupid to me
it's i don't like the royal thing you
don't i am team megan though
i feel like she was hor i feel like the
english are so
they're so obsessed i don't know what
that was
they're so cruel yeah they're so cruel
the stuff they say about her and
um it's it's crazy like i watched pierce
morgan go off about her and like that
whole thing i was like what is wrong
with these people they really want her
to [ __ ] kill herself like that
like oh for sure unbelievable and you
know there's lots of parallels to what
happened
to princess dye harry's mom right
and um the whole i think the whole
royalty should be disbanded dude it's
it's time to go
well who's gonna run the country then
royalty doesn't do anything they
literally are just a
ceremonial title you know that right you
know who runs the country the prime
minister in parliament
um you know that right yeah yeah hugh
grant love actually played the prime
minister
yeah hugh grant's running england we
don't need the royalty you remember how
boss you grant was and he just fell off
he was just like
banging prostitutes what happened to him
he was so cute he just figured out he
said he was right
ugly yeah no he didn't you showed me he
was a he was a
he was a leading man you showed me his
picture he told me i wouldn't [ __ ] him
he had a heart i'll tell you as jokes on
it
i'll definitely lick his butthole boy
getting a tiger ring with him
you know who else got kind of ugly who
used to be like the hottest dude who
val kilmer oh but he had cancer
oh he had throat cancer oh but he just
got like super fat and trust me i know
what that's like make your work
and his head got huge you got to see val
kimmer
i love valkyrie dan is this the best
image you can find what are we doing
here
anyway he just looks like he aged a bit
i want to call him ugly all right
i'm with you and i think he's ugly he's
just a bad person i feel actually i
don't know him we shouldn't say that
what
what is this hugh grant uh okay now look
what happened to his career i mean he
was about hammer monitoring
like that's probably what affected it he
had like tumors everywhere no he just
got
he just i don't know when he aged his
head got bigger and bigger and bigger
i love valkimer so obviously with all
the peace and love in the world
but hey guys remember when i was batman
i just don't get memes i hate when you
tell me memes because i don't get them
i'm like okay
i don't get me what's not to get what do
you guys are not funny like what's funny
about it i guess okay i remember when
you're batman cool
like what okay fair enough but what's
the
what's funny it's funny because he
doesn't because he's like out of shape
he's looking goofy okay cool cool i get
it
i can't explain the joke because i know
what i'm saying though is like i feel
like memes i just don't get like people
there's people who get memes and there's
people don't get memes
like sometimes we'll show myself on
reddit and i'm like i don't get it he'll
show me like reddit
all right let me okay well dude i said
okay do you know that ela
show the video please either ran into
david
dobrik yeah when i'll show i have a
video she filmed it
this is a skit no it's not here you're
ready i thought you were serious
here watch this what's this
she [ __ ] she kicked his ass dude
first of all what is that she threw
hands with david in the bathroom
what is this that's crazy huh who is
that
you look like threw hands with davis
she's like yo i'm not missing my
opportunity here
what is it i see them throwing hands
with david why does it look like them
though
that's so funny what is that it's a
video
it is not it yeah it was on the
subreddit oh shout out to the subreddit
i don't like
i don't like the subreddit moses is on
that thing and i don't get it and he
shows me he's like it's not funny
you guys are not funny stop what dude
separate
do not go against the subreddit they
love you oh okay
i love don't start war with the those
are the foot soldiers you really don't
like the football that's not funny keep
that for h3
girl you are about to lose your wikifee
rating i would watch what you say
i have a good rookie feet not for long
if you keep this [ __ ] up and nobody
cares about wikifeed except for you and
this is
so stupid you're gonna regret saying
that
i'm gonna set my army to go write your
wiki feet down everyone go to ethan's
wiki feed and write it down you don't
have a foot
army i have a foot army your foot army
has already
gave me five stars can we do feet things
on my only fans
you want no i'm not doing anything on
your own okay it makes fun of me
i need money i'm broke help me import
stop yeah i just want my mom a house i
feel like i lost all my money again
every time i buy a house
you buy your mom a house cash not cash
but kind of
nice yeah that's a nice daughter move
thanks
is she happy yeah good i don't think she
expected it my mom always like gave me
all her money even when she was broke
when i was like 18 19 to move to
hollywood so
i owe her my life you do that for your
parents don't you right mm-hmm
that's baller yeah i help my parents out
your parents are bougie
they are they look bougie they look like
professors and lawyers
really were they no no at all really my
mom was a hairdresser and my dad just
owned a bike store wait really yeah oh
[ __ ] they literally look like
they're definitely just salt of the
earth working people oh i love that
that's even cooler
oh so some other interesting
developments before we get to the
cook-off
our boy ringo starr at the grammys
spreading peace and love
i just want to give a shout out he's
going to block you i think about that
when you talk about him i'm like oh he's
[ __ ] blocked you think i could get
him to block me i mean i got o.j to
block me it'd be kind of happening
yeah he blocked me because when he
joined twitter i was like i'm going to
make it
my goal to get blocked by o.j simpson
and he did he blocked me
really yeah i once did and i love you
o.j simpson music video because i
thought it was like a clever troll which
is so not so gross now but
but um his people contacted me and asked
me if i wanted to go on a date with him
no
i don't know if this is real people i
don't get you you told that story before
but now you're really
revealing that his people contact you to
go on a date i think it was his people i
don't know for sure i don't want to say
allegedly
because i don't know for sure why didn't
you go on the day because you didn't
want to die
right no i always said that i would be
cool like i'm not cool but like
part of history to be killed by o.j
simpson it's kind of like you're on
vandal he killed one girl and then got
away with it and then the second girl
was the one that locked him up you know
i just want to give a shout out to my
boy ringo with peace do you think he
would block me with peace and love
yeah this is a serious message to ethan
klein i am blocking you with peace and
love
no more tweets thank you thank you
serious question do you think michael
star
competition oh god i'm having a gerd
moment
yeah for sure would you like us would
you invite him to your house or would
you be scared he know where you live
ringo yeah i'm not why would i be scared
of ringo's star like just having random
people come to your house i love ringo's
star
so if you like show up to your house and
start stalking you you're like okay i
wouldn't care ringo
stalking me yes i would be flattered
would you let him in or would you keep
him up five it's you're talking about
ringo stark okay okay you vitamin for
the cook off he comes once cool but now
he keeps coming back trying to hang out
would you invite him in or would you
keep him out
i'd probably be like listen ringo
i love you you did the beatles respect
all that [ __ ] i love what
everything you've done in your career
but i need a little space
wait so i know i totally thought
something else can i say this or no can
i show the piece in love
so a podcast asked me to be on their
podcast that said that you and hila were
a guest and like ask him how much fun it
was and i was like oh that's kind of a
weird thing to ask
wait wait wait wait wait what okay you
can tell this oh there's another one
this podcast like it's a pretty big
podcast asked me to be a guest on it
and they're like ethan and elon ethan
and ela were like
um guests on this podcast so you can ask
them how much fun it was that's what
they said in the evening
podcast um
it's the bobby lee one oh bobby's the
best you love
i love bobby why would they do that
though they're like why are they
leveraging me to get you to do it
i don't know but i love bobby lee um
it's kind of like you and ela right it's
like a couple yeah yeah they're awesome
i hate couples podcasts so don't do it i
just think couples who do podcasts
together are like horny like so many
people are doing it what about me and
hilo
now i love you guys but i'm just saying
like you know
everyone else that does it with their
boyfriend or girlfriend is corny good
we're the one exception
okay like we get it you both love each
other you both are the same person like
we get it you know what i mean
with peace and love not with peace and
love i mean people say what they do in
war
is that a thing yeah hate and war that's
the opposite of peace and love when you
mean
when it's all offense with people with
hate and war
i think i have a lot of hate in me i
need to get it out maybe or no with war
and hate sorry
i don't want war maybe just hate with
hate
and stop doing couples peace and love so
be with hate
and chaos another person said i like
that do you like hate and chaos
yeah i love chaos that makes me feel
like my childhood anyway
after a year when
it's great to be here in fact it's great
to be anywhere
because no matter what happens music
must go great yeah
so i'm honored to be here and the
grammys
as well i've been here many times before
and
uh with that other band i was in i was
in and i
want to say this with peace and love we
love you
you're making music in our world today
that's like his
thing this is a serious message yeah
that's his thing so you can never really
put it on merch because that's his thing
they're
like i can't put it on merch you just
need to trademark that [ __ ] you should
trademark it
i should trademark and sue ringo that'd
be [ __ ] awesome hey regal
you're saying my [ __ ] i'll show up as as
joe exotic shake him down
i know you're rich [ __ ] so
there's this dirt
oh this guy dom who apparently you're
saying
uh david was feeding girls alcohol to
sleep with so he put out a video
exposing david okay so
that's what's so crazy because he was
they must have reached out to him
comment one thing about the insider they
reach out to everyone for a comment like
they do like they
reach out to everyone so he must reach
out he must have known this article this
article is coming out which is cool but
like
address it like he didn't even address
it in the thing like he just he glazed
over everything other than saying like
yeah the wall cloud's kind of shitty
like i'm gonna just go on that like
page or saying like [ __ ] the vlog squad
but at the same time like you did really
shitty things like he didn't take any
accommodation let me show
uh um let me show a brief clip just to
give you guys context so this is the guy
we were talking about
that david was trying weird ads
i have youtube premium but it's on my
other account
what's the point i'm like logged into
the podcast in my main channel oh my god
it's so complicated so this is the guy
that david allegedly got alcohol for the
girls to sleep with
yes and so now he made a video
suddenly right before this article comes
out
saying you know what david
needs to deal with this and we were
[ __ ] up back then and we were bullies
right
which i get and that but so it's just
weird cuz i know there's accusations
again i don't know
i don't know anything about him he has a
lot of accusations i thought that was
bad the vidcon one this girl he was he's
allegedly essayed a girl like what got
on top of her wouldn't let her up like
that kind of thing she was like 17
in 2017 that happened um yeah i mean he
has like a lot of incidences against him
so
so here's him just talking briefly on
david's on the david situation
the situation that's going on between
seth and
david um you know that's something that
i think david
you know needs to handle seth has been
always a good supportive
friend of mine and he still is you know
it was kind of a pointless video to be
honest with you yeah because he didn't
address anything he's just trying to get
on the right side of it saying david
he's addressed it which he does but
you know he just never will which you
know i went back and saw
his because i was trying to understand
this whole vidcon thing because
apparently he's like a big drama
yeah and i saw on his video or he even
mentioned it in this video he said go
watch my video on the vidcon thing i was
like i don't know what happened to
vidcon
because i went and watched the apology
he made and he's like yo
i made a mistake i'm sorry i'm way too
aggressive with women yeah
but they all have overgel overwhelming
majority likes
and good response and the top comment of
that video which maybe i'll go check and
see if it's still there
is david saying hey mistakes happen it's
all good buddy
on the of course on that apology of
course
so i don't know what to make of these
guys i just it's just it just sucks but
but he says like yeah we used to bully
people like this guy jonah it's not i
didn't know his name wasn't even jonah
his name's nick and they just make fun
of him because he looks like jonah hill
well it's the one that i told you
they haven't flashed everybody because
his penis is so small so like jonah show
everyone your penis and like i don't
want to see arenas why is he doing that
oh it's so bad karma comes around
i know i've gotten karma hit bad so it
comes around with like shitty people
um and then there's that fire deleted
his video though like right after oh
yeah he deleted we didn't talk about
that
yeah oh i wanted to ask you see there's
there's stuff to get to
let me pull up the scotty apology and i
want to know
what your comment is on that here let me
pull it up also stop doing twitter notes
if you make a whole ass youtube video
make a whole ass youtube video also
learn to crop your notes dumbass like
i'm sorry how about prop your [ __ ]
note because it showed up on my feed
just like a white square and i was like
[ __ ] how long have you been on the
internet
crop your [ __ ] bro
why did he guilty that video that's like
the dumbest when we have our steamies
next year like the dumbest movie should
go to scotty's life
i forgot about the steamies i'm so
excited
we should rent a venue if the pandemic's
over and get like
have a live audience okay that seems
like
something should we have a ticketed
event oh yeah
i love it the steamies we're going on
tour
if no one comes people are coming
through this thing
oh yeah okay so anyway scotty sayer who
doesn't know how to crop a note said
hi again hi again
hi again okay cause he's left oh right
hi again stop it they're so cringy
first of all i would like to apologize
to anyone who feels as though i
disrespected or invalidated their story
how about seth specifically
that was never my intention and i mean
that so sincerely well it was
specifically your intention to
invalidate seth's story that was
your explicit express intention
i let emotions get the better of me and
i chose my
uh approach and many of my words poorly
i chose to make the video and share my
opinion i expected it to be analyzed and
picked apart but i did not expect it to
hurt so many people and so i've made the
decision to remove the video from my
channel it wasn't your opinion you
literally said that's not the truth seth
you told a lie
you're literally just you're literally
invalidating this yeah exactly
so i responded i said scotty with peace
and love of course
you didn't just choose the wrong words
you ignored that david so his video like
ignored pretty much
every major development including i said
you ignored
that david admitted to the pranks being
racially motivated
you ignored that the first prank was not
consensual like you can debate the
second one i think this
the second one was not consensual you
know pranks are by definition not
consensual and they were and
but david and jason have admitted that
the second one he had no idea
that's but so yeah but like the first
one you
you can't even debate it right so you he
ignored that the first rank was not
consensual and he
indirectly threatened the victim and
tried to assassinate his character while
bringing up like the revenge keywords
right right i was like bro just [ __ ]
own it like there's some [ __ ]
apology this is like david dobrik level
when he did the
native american spit he put an apology
video going
apology to everyone offended an apology
to everyone who wasn't offended
because uh other people were offended or
something so stupid
you know or when he i liked on you much
on the h3 podcast when jason said he got
bullied for being a jew
and david i'm gonna watch that because i
found that one really disturbing because
that's
crazy like that's his mentality like he
literally like thinks that way which is
like so
but now even seeing all this how like
just they really are not sorry because i
always thought it's weird you know david
ever reached out to me and like
apologized but like he's just like not
sorry
and he actually thinks he did everything
right and he's in the right of
everything and i'm like that's [ __ ]
crazy to me that's insane
i'm gonna pull up my tick tock because
this isn't i cut it down a bit it's
really long and i think it's better to
watch like this
yeah just watch this this is to me as a
as a jew especially i mean
and as someone who's just not unless
jason is half a jew i don't know if that
matters probably not i mean he got
bullied for being a jew so whatever
is dude you got to stop the jewish
gatekeeping first of all he tricked me i
thought he was a full jew and then he's
like actually my mom's only jewish i'm
like ah
yeah that's full of jews okay but his
dad's like catholic i want
you you want jewish purity i need yeah
that's what i'm trying to get you gotta
stop bro
why because it's it's it's weird it's
weird how you fetishize jewish people
fatter sizing
totally in the upper echelon of the
world that's not
that's not okay dude why
because i like jewish people no because
you don't understand no because you
don't understand the religion or the
culture at all
oh what are you talking about because
you're saying he's not a real first of
all you're
you're gatekeeping you're not even
jewish you're saying how come i can't
gatekeep but everyone else can get keep
on the internet
you're not even jewish semantics
it's literally not semantics it's more
like
yeah it's it's semitic jewish people
appreciate it
the important ways jewish he appreciated
my love for jews
well saying the jews are the upper
echelon of the world is definitely isn't
that a compliment
listen i'm not saying there's no peter
no that's why everyone wants to kill us
is because they've got this whole
[ __ ] no because they've got these
weird
world domination uh conspiracies because
jews get to go to heaven you're like one
you're like
one tippy toe away from wanting to
exterminate all jews
you know what i mean like it starts it
starts with intrigue
it starts with fetishizing and then it
starts with we need to kill them all
i just don't get it but okay i'm sorry
that i have i have a preference
you can have preference jewish men okay
but you can't be like i was mad at my
boyfriend because he's
only his mom was just but that's like
okay that's like someone's like weird
i'm
i don't want to use this term oh it's
just like if someone tricked you right
if someone's like hey you didn't trick
me i was born a girl i have
a second baby and then you're not a girl
he said he was jewish
he is jewish thank you he is jewish
literally in the last episode you got
mad because someone's dad was jewish and
they claimed there was jewish
now you're mad at jason because his mom
was jewish who that technically makes
you jewish and you're mad because his
dad wasn't jewish
the jewish law in the religion is that
if your mom is jewish that makes you
jewish
okay so who are you i respect my
statement and not that i even give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
no i just think it's odd you went to
israel
to find your wife i went to israel for a
free trip and i happened to
meet ela see you i literally never even
dated a jewish girl before how about
this though if jewish people aren't
bachelor how come you guys get free
trips to israel and i don't i want a
free trip
yeah what does it have to do with
because you guys get privileges like
getting a free trip to israel i would
love a free trip to israel how come i
don't get that
i mean exactly exactly got you
not just you're so confused
how does me getting a free how is me
getting a trip to
israel make me upper echelon because i
don't get it so you have privilege over
me
well i'm sure you have other privilege
like how about not getting coins tossed
at your feet and being called pick it up
dirty too
you know what people have tossed bacon
at me and said eat it pig
no well that's cause you're fat with you
yeah but you have above but you have
control over
over your weight non-jews have it worse
than fat jews
fat jews have it worse than non-fat yeah
okay
no other way around but i got it you
like whatever it doesn't matter
hmm that's not better than a non-jew fat
person
right interesting point i can see
bacon okay thank you i concede
all right let's watch this of david
jason says he
faced lots of anti-semitism growing up
horrible things he mentions like people
used to throw pennies at his feet and
say pick it up jill call him a dirty jew
anyway just listen to this um
they call me dirty jew
yeah i was the only jewish kid in the
school shut up did you get [ __ ] for that
all the time
you walk down the hallway someone just
throw a penny on the ground oh and
everyone would laugh that used to happen
at my school but that's not
[ __ ] that's unless you're like a
sensitive like [ __ ] about it
so exactly you want me to go back
listen to this listen to the news that's
like a weird turn no i mean like i know
teachers that would make you dirty jew
jokes like because it's just
what it's not bad they're just words and
like i think bro
are you a normal straight white dude
gonna come here and tell me words are
just words you had a teacher that told a
jew joke
we had really cool teachers really oh my
god this is good
oh my god i think he's i don't want to
say it but i think allegedly maybe in my
head this is not defamatory
maybe a white supremist or something no
well
white supremacist yeah that's crazy
who is it like i mean i had a teacher
that was so cool confused
well also i find it rich that he goes he
has uh
jason he goes did you ever get [ __ ] for
it and then jason goes yes i did get
[ __ ] for it
and then david goes no you didn't get
[ __ ] for you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he asked him the question i mean i don't
know what he expected the guy said
people threw pennies at my feet and told
me to pick it up if that's not [ __ ] i
don't know what it is wait i don't
really get that though okay yeah but
that's besides the point got it yeah
these are greedy that's the oh really
yeah
that's like a com that like i think back
in the day they're like pick it up jew
you [ __ ] greedy jew oh yeah i'd pick
it up and i'm not even a jew
you would pick up the penny for sure
penny kept penny earned that's what
benjamin franklin said
penny saved is a penny earned so that's
worse than what i'm i'm saying i like
jews he's that's worse
yes okay so it's not equivalent you're
like i'm not comparing you i'm just
saying you got your own issues away from
wanting to
un-alive well i make i'm making a joke
because
you're like the only person that's been
so obsessed with jews is hitler as far
as i'm aware
you know what i'm saying right you're
like you flip with the same coin okay
you know what i mean i get the reference
i i can you know who hitler is now
we've come a long way in the show
haven't we i love that we always talk
about jewish arguments trivia did not
slap last week i did not get three
million views no one's everyone's like
we don't care about jewish trivia
three million is that your goal post now
i thought it did really well
three million yeah thank you honestly
i'm shocked we even get a million every
time we get a million like oh he's got
over a million like i am very excited
for real that's and i'm
trying to be humble i'm actually like
wow that's crazy i'm just scared for it
to end like one day
it's gonna get under a million views and
i'm gonna be like oh man we still
disappointed but
it's still fine i'll still do it until
the ship stays just enjoy baby just
enjoy the ride
last week's episode has three million
views that's insane that's insane
don't care about jews that's really you
understand that's so crazy
crazy especially because we were doing
like trivia i feel like this one's kind
of sinking a little bit
today you got to drop that we're just
having fun we're chit-chatting we're
we're chewing and driving we're shooting
again we're feeling and driving i'm part
of the june enjoy
i'm doing you're driving um can we dress
like the titanic survivors next week
maybe
what's the titanic survivor i don't know
you just said like the sinking in the
ship so i thought maybe titanic
i think they just wear like old-timey
stuff maybe like freezing over
okay that's a little sensitive well how
else are you supposed to do it
yeah so how else am i supposed to drive
the life jacket
i don't like can we get oh okay i have
more can we have billy zane on the show
oh for sure he did cameo he'll totally
do it he's on cameo yeah
she's good with him what did he what did
you famous i wanted him to pick out my
fast food order for me like what's your
favorite fast food it was for a video
like i got charlie sheen to do it i got
billy zane to do it they picked out
their favorite fast food item is that so
humiliating for them
it is yeah like these guys were
a-listers and now they're on cameo
ordering fast food for trisha
i mean [ __ ] cameo has really changed
[ __ ] carol baskins is on it that cameo
was made for people like caravastia
then you got zorro he used to be zorro
yes yeah wait who
billy shane oh i just know from titanic
as the [ __ ] boyfriend
um
yeah he was great in titanic
premium i'm losing my [ __ ] here um i
just wanted to show this
who is it billy zane no it's
this was after a 16 year old said that
james charles was sending him nudes oh
we're back to james
exchanging exchanging nudes and then one
stay later
really rarely ever do here on this
channel and that is a
makeup review i don't do makeup reviews
very often you guys know by now i really
tend to use a lot of the same products
every single time that i get i do
uh social reviews snapchat is my
favorite social platform for picking up
underage boys because it erases your
your messages automatically and unless
someone violates my trust and
yeah i would like to see that to switch
it up and do really just fun
entertaining videos for y'all however i
went to the mailbox yesterday to just
open up some packages
see what came in and i got this very
interesting box from
[Music]
did you get your passports did you
get your shots and when i opened it
like four to five times a year this is
so embarrassing why would they sponsor
him
yeah the day all his bonds are taken
away oh his life is ruined i know you're
friends with him but or not friends but
you're friendly with him but did you see
his last podcast
i didn't watch it oh my gosh like he's
so depressed it's so sad i mean it's
so sad but yeah yeah
yeah i've been following him on
instagram just for like kind of like
morbid curiosity to be honest yeah same
because we'll be tired of the last one
humans so i know we're not supposed to
we're not supposed to talk about
podcasts on here right but
like let me just talk about this because
the last one you're like oh don't talk
about other people's sponsors kidding
you could talk about other people's
customers oh that's like don't talk
about people okay
no i don't care okay well anyways um
wait really no but okay he said he lost
all his sponsors like right and he
absolutely and he was talking about how
like he lost like all his like oh he
said he used to do like favors for
friends like cameos and they're like
crappy movies or whatever and they get
called them up and said like oh we're
cutting you from the movie or whatever
i mean look obviously okay so he lost
all the sponsors for his podcast he's
like literally so depressed
and you can tell he's just like i hate
like everything in my life right now
okay
but um but meanwhile james charles and
david dover get sponsored by triple m
maybe there's your pawns of chris leah
chipotle that's a great opportunity
let's get let's get crystalline his own
order
you know well there was that lawsuit
that came out like right after he came
back to social media
and i was like oh that's disgusting what
was alleged
in the lawsuit was like really gross
that he was like he took her virginity
and it was like a king for him
and it was is it real well she's suing
him and she says it's real i mean i mean
yeah if you're suing someone then you
probably have some truth to it because
she apparently has receipts and texts
and images and all this [ __ ] why is he
still doing a podcast
i think that's a good question but also
like at the same time
okay i brought that up not to sean
crystalia because i i watch him but
again it's like more average just being
like whoa oh my god like is he okay
which is sad like but people watch me
for that reason too it's fine not
anymore i'm not gonna anyways
but he can't wait not to hide the point
too but i thought it was so interesting
because like
all these people are still getting
sponsored and he's not and i was like
why why wouldn't they yeah because
i hate to keep saying this because maybe
i'm not even right
but my hunch is that because and again
okay there's a few
theories i have because they're young
that his fans are young
james charles and david's fans are young
and so they don't understand the gravity
and they don't give a [ __ ]
the other theory i have which i'm again
i don't
i don't want i don't even like saying
this because i don't want our
our women audience to think i'm
invalidating their experience
because i think they go through the same
[ __ ] but i do think that maybe
the fact that the victims are men have
something to do with it
too but again and but i don't even like
saying that because you know what
i everyone is yeah everyone goes to
because that's like implies that the
like you
know women survivors have it easy easier
in some way
like i don't know i don't want anyone i
just don't really feel bad for these
people actually because at first i was
like oh my god i kind of feel bad for
like joe exotic crystalia but i kind of
don't feel bad joe exotic
because he was kind of everything but i
mean don't hire
people to kill people right
i think he thought he was going to get
pardoned by trump right he really did he
tried to
dude isn't that so awesome like what a
character like he really thought trump
was going to pardon him
wouldn't it be iconic though if trump
did do it because honestly i feel like
people wouldn't even be mad
yeah maybe they'd be like yeah it's
trump what can you do he pardoned joe
exotic
like i feel like people kind of expected
it
oh [ __ ] could i um but anyway i was
going
to visit him you can like visit cat
inmates sure you can go visit your
exotic really do they have to come visit
you
no he can reject you oh you know he's
not like a slave
oh
but you can ask um so james got
sponsored
okay we're going to have the cook off
and then the other thing is that like
two days afterwards he collapsed with a
six-year-old boy
named jimmy in it he collapsed
what's the bluest one james i don't
understand this oprah blue highlighter
that's pretty good
they're playing minecraft oh james i'm
sure you love
minecraft you uh hi
sisters you want to play minecraft
together in my home
in our underwear why did he do that show
me your armpit hair while we played
minecraft sister
sickness like he doesn't get it like
it's a sickness like he literally needs
to be with these young kids it's like
really weird
i mean it's so odd oh my other favorite
james charles thing
since we're on the topic is that after
he apologized and he was like you know
what
i got to check people's ids now remember
that whole apology
so even after he put that out was like i
was wrong he's out
liking fans who are trashing and
victim shaming the person that he preyed
upon oh my god he liked this tweet
someone said
didn't think i'd be saying something but
this james charles scandal has gone far
too far for once and i'm on james's side
because about two years ago i spoke to
the same guy
who's from palm beach florida he added
me randomly off snapchat yadda yadda
yadda
this random ass 16 year old kid this
random note saying oh i talked to him
too and he lied about his age
like somehow that makes it better is
that he's like we know he lied about his
age you're the [ __ ] adult james how
so he's going liking tweets like just
sitting on his victim that's
so weird dude has is such a sick [ __ ]
and chipotle's like hi sisters
did they say that did they tweet that
probably did you tweet chipotle
i did okay chipotle if you're sponsoring
david doe burke and james charles just
put crystalline on there too
yeah baby name it the um
name it the the spring chicken burrito
you know spring chicken they're like not
they're like that's funny
but i don't know if that's funny but you
know seriously
the spring chicken burrito do you have a
spring chicken oh yeah oh james charles
special yep
what would david dobrik's burrito
special be called
his would be called the um
hmm
it would be some kind of like yeah i
don't know his accusations are a little
more esoteric that's kind of yeah
it's hard to define hard to define yeah
oh cause he's just such a bad person
no what would my spotlight be extra sour
cream extra guac
extra cheese extra cheese
yeah soggy beef sandwich the big it
would be called the big [ __ ]
oh i like the big [ __ ] burrito oh okay
yeah
i would eat that the big machine yeah i
like that
yeah i like that too i tweeted this out
people actually get mad at me you know
i'm generally against like cancel
culture but
like we have to acknowledge in this
conversation that sometimes
people deserve to be canceled people are
so [ __ ] there are people
who do terrible things are we talking
about someone making an off-color joke
on twitter five years ago i mean that's
stupid obviously like i'm not going to
engage in that type of cancel culture
but james charles is a predator
woody allen definitely deserves to be
canceled and look how long he's been out
there yeah
it's like charles i think it's just
funny that people get like oh don't tag
the sponsor it's like bro what am i
supposed to do just let this guy
go run free don't take the sponsor they
should know about it
yeah like what the [ __ ] that's so crazy
i said yes to answer your question i am
trying to cancel james charles he of all
people is completely deserving
after admitting to exchanging dudes with
the six-year-old there's a pattern of
behavior that should land him in prison
not collaborating with chipotle
sorry for real that's not yeah that's
crazy
so um oh there's one other thing i
wanted to
add which is that we
i don't know if you heard about this
whole ntf thing the non-fungible tokens
sorry i'm it's not a pick it's a itch
you ever pick your nose no i'm not
picking my nose
there's an itch from the mustache here
oh nose picking's like not that gross to
me
i've i hate it it's disgusting but i
just want i don't do it but i don't
it's a scratch not a pic you think it's
disgusting i guess yeah people like
shoving their finger on their nose
and then you know they always go to the
mouth you see that somewhere i've never
seen that
you see people go to the mouth all the
time bro i can't do it yeah
okay so we made these so ntfs this are
just
it's digital art and they're using this
new technology called crypt
uh called blockchain technology oh yeah
i know but but
hear me skip passes on the age hear me
out because i want to make frenemies
ntfs what is the point of it it's like
digital trading cards i want to make
them for every outfit we have
now if you think i'm being stupid we
made as a gag
we made coins for everybody okay
dan ian a b zach everybody made five
coins for two thousand dollars a piece
and they all sold out oh sounds like a
scam
it is yeah i know it feels like a scam
so why are we doing
it for friendly i don't want to be
involved no it's not a scam it's real
people love collecting this [ __ ]
it's not a scam you sell it people buy
it but we made 80 000
just selling these [ __ ] like dan's
even dan's was even i
i have a bridge to sell you who are you
giving the money to
to the guys oh yeah the thousand dollars
yeah you made ten thousand dollars yes
they each made ten thousand dollars and
we were everywhere
like we don't understand this and i
don't think you should buy this this is
stupid dan's
literally is i've got a bridge to sell
you i don't like it and dan just bought
it you don't you don't think it would be
cool to make uh
trading cards with all of our outfits
like different outfits we've
are you keeping the coin no of course
i'm gonna share it with you okay
you always think i'm not of course i'm
going to share it with you
hmm why are you making that i'm not i
just said okay
of course i'm gonna share with you what
is that like what is it gonna be
okay for example like me and drag as
jeffree star
and you are like you dressed as me and
me just as you for example like we would
make like a trading card
and put it up it's just fun and what do
you got to do you have to like do a chat
weekly or what
like a live chat no it's just it's a we
just we make the card why don't you just
screenshot that and then you got it
boom because listen i'm not i'm not like
a proponent i don't even
i'm not here buying or like i'm not
propos
proposing anything where's that
frenemy's nft i just think it's really
interesting that we made eighty thousand
dollars in a gag
and a gag do you understand what i'm
saying we literally just did it for a
gag
anyway there's gonna be this is a shout
out a little bit shout out to you
we made it and we put it on this website
what website you can't say it's no i can
say it's open c dot io
open seed open c
cool but we made it we made a one of one
vape
god token the vape nation video is going
on bid live
this friday the bid is going to expire
during the show live this friday you're
not going to want to miss this
spectacular star treasure spectacular
friday episode
this point is going live live live so
head on over to openc dot is just
elaborate roosters to promote the coin
openc dot io slash activity slash and
uh uh or not not subjectivity open c dot
io slash n
h3 h3 dash nft thank you when are we
getting ours
okay so you want to do it so we can do
it for now i want this broken bag that's
198 thousand dollars so how much do i
have
to get that bag what how many coins
so much that's like how do i get how
much do i have to sell of those coins
i don't know you never know how much
it's gonna go for i mean these could be
valuable you want
it's like 198 thousand dollars for my
coin okay there you go
this purse is oh 195 000. that's a funny
guy
it's 195 thousand dollars what is it
made out of ostrich
how many houses they killed to make that
bag i don't know they're like a whole
farm let's do it ethan let's do one of
one for trisha
and set the price to 105. yeah yeah you
never know who's going to buy it that's
all
put me with my birkin kate yeah dan was
like there's no way
i was the biggest guy nobody is going to
buy any of these
and then like a week later we've sold
eighty thousand dollars buying it for
them
no you can see who buys it it's all
bubbles it would do something like that
well i'm not that nice okay can you put
prepped me with my birken cake on there
they each they already got paid out
these guys tenth grand
um okay baller
oh my god i didn't realize that was
fully undone was the whole undone the
whole time
yeah wow i don't think i've ever seen
your chest before do you think
you got a lot of hair that was good but
like not too much you look like
reynolds maybe you should cosplay as him
next burt reynolds did he have the
perfect chest hair yeah
oh his chest hair was everything all
right we got to wrap it up let's go cook
some food what do you think
i'm so excited are we eating it or
they're tasting it well
you got to taste your cookies okay okay
all right we'll see you guys upstairs
okay we are in the top chef kitchen we
are thinking of
names for this more like uh mercury chef
for you
because it causes birth defects cancer
it also causes birth defects if you eat
chips
so we're starting with the noodles could
i also take a cup of your pasta water
real quick
wow go ahead no excuses pasta
pasta water is the dumbest it's just
going to be like it's not
it's such a scam like you're telling me
that like a cup of
noodles cooked in pasta is going to make
all the difference it emulsifies it
it makes it a butter sauce instead of
butter noodles you know how i already
want no i'm going to win the pasta round
because you didn't salt your water i did
fill my water you missed it i don't know
why you have like all the way up water
like a whole
i salted my water you missed it she
takes the water she takes the salt
shaker and does like this
you know you missed it damn girl that is
buttered
noodles well that's a secret are you
sure you're emulsifying and not just
mixing butter into it
emulsifying it do you get like sexual
about this
no but i do get really excited so
i will body fall asleep oh my god i know
ooh that'd be a good name for a weed
dispensary
bougie bowls that's stupid while we
complete our noodle dish i'd like to
introduce our three judges
the beautiful unbiased as it gets
fair as it gets culinary expert ceo
ela klein on your judgment yes
next up is the legendary musician
friend great all-around great guy we
love him
do you have credentials to be judging
our food uh 25
italian blood
[Applause]
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna you know take
it as it comes and be as truthful as i
can be
we love that we love to hear it thank
you to mack up next of course is as
everyone knows him water itself
we're gonna have to wipe up after him
water moses is here ladies and gentlemen
last time you know we had a competition
like this we were decorating cakes and
trisha won because everyone was scared
to vote against her
i know everyone was no and literally
everyone in the comments was like oh
trisha just won because the crew is
scared everyone in the comments always
says i want i want the physical fitness
i win everything you cheat on everything
ew ugh
you know what time it is that looks so
nasty
oh my god no
the rule was that we would make our best
pasta dish
well that was so not the rule trisha you
remembered things whatever you want
a big ziti grape but i didn't know it
was a pasta dish cook off i thought i
was like
you're making mac and cheese yes i'm
making mac and cheese because we have
mac demarco so you know
they all will get in good points with
the same name
i'm trying to try to tune into his box
with butter noodles
we can name it after him because mac and
cheese you don't like
no it's great i mean oh no that's mine
don't do it on my
job look at that look at that
ethan's world famous
mac demarco mac and cheese
it's like the mac and cheese i used to
have at the ymca when i was a kid that's
not a confidence
oh it's good it's good i can't counselor
that's points for nostalgia for me
okay i like that this also reminds me of
like you know the hot shelf at vaughn's
no but don't get me wrong i mean they're
good they slap hard
i love these mac and cheese yeah yeah
that's been sitting there you know
since the beginning of the day 7.5 okay
i'm happy with that the pasta is cooked
well
thank you very much thank you chef
consistency is good
i like how sticky it is thank you eight
out of ten
that's a good rainbow
i think it's perfect oh my god bias
give it a rating just do not seem
ridiculous i'll give it a 9 out of 10.
all right thank you she wanted to give
it a 10. but we'll take a knife
here comes the hater yeah it just tastes
like nachos and pasta and like
nachos yeah come on it tastes like a
lunchable
my hands are clean everybody my hands
are clean with peace and love
mac is going first as our celebrity
i'll say another staple of the ymca
daycare that i get
parmesan it adds a bit of class i'm
going to tell you that right now okay
shredded i shredded it myself it's sharp
parmesan you shredded it yourself you
act like you made it
yeah the parmesan you can taste that
fresh grating
out of 10 i'll give it an 8. by the way
i'm 14
italian
wouldn't that make you 14 italian and
says three you guys have the same
parents right oh [ __ ]
welcome to club pasta itself is cooked
perfect the butter
the parmesan let's make it quick a good
eight out of ten i will say i'm
not a fan of parmesan oh wow then we
lost with that one
i'm gonna give it a seven and a half
judges
talks amongst yourself in private just
based on you know the heritage of my
blood my roots i'm gonna have to go with
spaghetti so that's once
it sounds like there's no butter all
right
i came here expecting to eat pasta
spaghetti
with butter parmesan cheese that's an
italian cheese right there
yeah mac and cheese not as italian okay
thank you thank you it was not a it
wasn't saying i don't like mac and
cheese
okay you doing your best deniro over
there
so we're working on the potatoes this is
round two after my crushing defeat
thanks to my
one mac demarco aka judas i didn't know
that but you're welcome glad he invited
him now if you want to talk texture go
ahead and get a look at this ian
there's nothing in this yet i am just
mashing i am whipping i am working on
the texture
this is the most important thing is to
get all the moisture out and to whip up
that perfect texture but you could sell
this with potatoes it's called
mashed potatoes okay girl look at that
that looks [ __ ] disgusting look at
this there's just a stick of butter
floating in it it's not done
i've actually never cooked for anybody
except for moses this is my first time
cooking for people it's very
intimidating
oh my god jeez you're a guy fairy i'm
like paula deen
a couple fatties in the kitchen i love
that no not fatties
i love paul dean's eraser so maybe
that's not a good example love those
huge sticks of unmelted butter on top
that's definitely going to make all the
difference i'm sorry take a look at that
texture
that is [ __ ] chef boy or d [ __ ] and i
didn't mean that
not as like a to make fun of myself
because it sounds about ready
yeah that's a
you want to try mine mm-hmm mm-hmm
pile bobby
[Laughter]
i'm going with this pile here
this it's tasty but it's a mush of
something
this is potatoes this is like potato
you can just say that you can't go
against trisha let me take a taste
i'm sorry yeah it's like baked potato
with
butter come on
that is
[Laughter]
lack of salt is very that's essential
sounds like that so ethan thank you for
coming together and making the right
decision on this
moses you've shown your shoe colors
today but i still love you aspect
brother-in-law forever so we are moving
on to round three
we are moving on to the scrambled eggs
is that dog food yeah putting dog food
in mine no
what is that my special recipe dog food
[ __ ] olives
oh you got an interesting thing here
you're going heavy on the white
i do heavy egg white and just two yolks
what's that strategy
it just tastes better it makes them
fluffier okay we're gonna throw some
olives in forget about it
oh you put too much see i'm a basic
basic with babish
i have an interesting strategy i don't
use oil because the cheese has a lot of
oil at the end you put cheese in your
eggs
yeah oh it's not omelette no it's
scrambled eggs
yeah so you don't put cheese in
scrambled eggs bam bam
what is with you and cheese man oh my
god all right we've got some beautiful
fluffy cheddar with some black olives
master class and eggs
not the cheese isn't hitting me well
maybe it's a good thing i guess i don't
know
so i was going it's more of an
impression it's more of a flavor the
olives
kind of wild style not mad at it good
but first time for me really yeah in
eggs yeah
i love it
maybe
let's go 7.5 again okay oh my god okay
olives are my favorite part okay well
i'm not sure how to feel about that but
we like it we're an olive family
with we love olives and everything
so classic thank you
right out of the pan that's a good
strategy though yeah right
oh wow it does make this look very
orange
it is orange it's just an egg i didn't
add orange
food coloring to it it's an egg grandpa
used to make
eggs on the barbecue in the morning
before everybody woke up nice salt and
pepper so
i'm gonna give these eggs an eight wow
wow
repeating itself i love the salt and
pepper
and i love the way it feels just the
bite because of the white eggs i do like
white eggs more
that's it that's a nine wow
[Music]
okay so we are moving on to the final
stage that's the steak
stage the steak stage yeah two to one i
need the steak
okay but i feel confident in the steak
i've never cooked a steak so
so if you beat me i'm just gonna die
yeah baby don't die but i'll die
okay metaphorically speaking you'll die
nope
secret secret sauce is the butter holy
[ __ ]
literally more butter it simmers down
actually i've never made six i actually
have no idea but i think it simmers do
you flip steak
or do you just like no no you don't flip
it's like a sunny side egg
we have here a beautiful cut of
centerpiece fillet
salt and pepper is the vehicle above the
flavor
but the art itself is timing
execution know-how no it's butter for me
i don't know what i'm doing at all get a
close-up of that
it just literally doesn't cut i don't
understand i cut these all the time
oh my god that's like not even an onion
because i make quesadillas all the time
with onions and that is so not an onion
so not an onion that's garlic
onion guys what is going on here
it looks like an onion oh my god i don't
have that
you don't know the difference between
onion and garlic this is too much oh my
god
okay girl what are you doing
you can't tell which one is which no you
can't i know what mine are mine or a
little don't put on my
get that off my [ __ ] plate trisha get
it off i know which one it
is oh my god i know what to do get it
out out
okay put those on there put all yours on
one then there are three people you have
your own place where are you talking
oh my god so many dishes for your
housekeeper
so mean really don't worry about my
housekeeper worry about your [ __ ]
steaks oh my god maybe you should
oh my god i feel like i'm gonna are you
sure you took the right ones
are you kidding you don't know you're on
steak i thought your dick was so amazing
they look the same these are literally
not the same
oh my god which one you eating
nutritious
it's the inspection pink nice brown on
the outside
beautiful let's go straight
yeah yeah wow that's good
it's not not you know sometimes you know
especially with the thin piece of meat
like that
sometimes overcooked no it's good to go
well it's cooked to perfection
that's for sure yeah the temperature and
all i'm so
it's really good now we're moving over
round two visual inspection
pink well here i think we can see it's a
little more defined here with the gray
we got the flipping right
it's kind of interesting what's
interesting to me is like this one was
you know
cooked in butter but look at we got the
a bit more of a pool over here
that's also a good steak little you got
a little more crisp
to it i can taste the pepper
honestly it's really hard to tell like
which is which
yeah they're both really good again a
lot of flavor
from the seasoning but you know me i'm a
pure guy
stop you can't come into my kitchen and
say you don't want seasoning
i like cheese steak i didn't i'm so
objective i do like i just i like the
butter
i think the oil fries this thing too
much i think i think the butter just let
the
steak on your head
i'm gonna have to go with ethan
what is the standing right now with all
the food where are we at how many points
you two gonna want
two
i think today
i'm giving it to trish
[Applause]
congratulations
well you started it looked like a
disaster it did look like yeah
but you stole it you you seared it out
thank you
you got to take into account too it's
the first time she cooked this thing no
you did not have to take that
i appreciate all your cooking on youtube
and i'll continue to do it
can i tell you to be fair like i ate the
rest of your potatoes off moses's plate
and not mine so i did like your potatoes
better
thank you i'm gonna take the l another
l i can't stop losing to trisha
it's a well-deserved one thank you so
you're the new um
teflon birth defect okay
i hope you all enjoyed thank you to our
guest uh celebrity judge matt demarco
so we wrapped it up didn't we how many
times i got to wrap it
for watching up for watching
[Music]
you